do we try to fight back against the
machines and reclaim our dominance of
the cognitive niche
or do we try and retreat from the
cognitive leash and
let the kind of machines watch over us
and look after
our economic well-being our needs our
kind of the needs for abundance and
affluence and so forth and do something
else
before we get started there is a very
famous brazilian jiu jitsu teacher who
shares your name did you know this
i am all too aware of this fact yeah
yeah so
i i've posted a big list of upcoming
guests
on my instagram no like i didn't know
that you're interested in brazilian
jiu-jitsu
and i'm thinking does a guy who talks
about
that automation and robots also do
brazilian jiu jitsu training but it
turns out that it's just
it's just two different interesting
people
yeah you're um your fans probably got
very excited when they thought it was
the other
john denner he's got a much higher
profile than me little do they know that
they actually wanted to learn about
robots so what what are we going to be
talking about today what's the what's
the topic of our discussion
yeah so we're going to talk about this
book that i wrote a couple years ago on
automation and utopia which is kind of a
very
you know abstract philosophical look at
the meaning of life
in a post-work world if if robots take
all our jobs away
what are we going to do with our time
and will we be able to
find meaning and flourish these sorts of
questions are very common
at the moment i think you know it seems
like every other week
someone's referring to like when the
robots take our jobs in a news article
yeah i mean it's been a fairly
persistent theme in
popular media and kind of academic
discussions as well for the past decade
or so i'd say it really kind of took off
after the
2008 financial crisis and the subsequent
recession
ironically it was probably starting to
ebb away a little bit
more recently due to the uptick in the
economy in the past couple years but i
think kovac 19 has really
kick-started the discussion once more an
interesting thing i
heard today on ben shapiro's show was
about joe biden raising the u.s minimum
wage to 15
uh encouraging many employers
to replace workers with automation
precisely for that reason like if it
costs x
thousand ten thousand hundreds of
thousands of pounds to install the robot
system
the more that you raise the minimum wage
the more and more that becomes
competitive
yeah i mean i think like economics 101
would tell you if you raise the price of
anything it raises the price of labor
you're going to make it less attractive
for employers
uh there i don't know exactly whether
the
rise in the minimum wage in the us to 15
would would kickstart a wave of
automation or whether we're in fact in
the midst of a wave anyway that
you know this is just a kind of a minor
and nudge along the path
there was an interesting world economic
forum
report a couple of months ago about the
impact of kova 19 on automation which
had a survey of business leaders around
the world and the percentage of them
that were
looking to um automate their workforce i
think it was about
41 of employers are looking to increase
the amount of automation
at the moment and then i believe it's
again somewhere
in the 40 percentage range of people who
want to
increase the amount of outsourcing of
labor that they do and there's only a
handful of
of employers that were actually going to
expand the workforce
in the wake of 19.
is human obsolescence imminent
yeah i mean that's the sentence that i
use to open the
the book and it's uh a little bit of
hyperbole that's what i've said to
everybody that's interviewing me and
this is a little bit of
rhetorical hyperbole i think that
the obsolescence is you know becoming
less useful in certain endeavors
or growing out of fashion or something
like that
you know the same way like your phone
obsolesces over time it becomes
taken over by better technology so the
the idea that i start the book with is
this sense that maybe humans are
obsolescing in more and more more and
more domains of activity and
we've seen this historically happen in
agriculture
and manufacturing industries being the
classic examples of
obsolescence due to technology and now i
think we're
starting to see it in a range of other
professions from
you know finance to the law profession
even into branches of government where
there is increased use of
automated technologies like you know
algorithmic prediction tools
or robotics to replace human workers
or human decision makers how about
rolling that forward
there's a lot of talk about well yeah
robots might have been able to
replace weavers and and and
plowers and stuff like that but they're
not going to be able to replace more
complex things
yeah i mean there's a famous um paradox
it was invented by a guy called hans
moravik in back in the late 80s with
more of x paradox which is about the
fact that um a lot of what we
what we historically have called kind of
abstract
thought um kind of high level
thinking is actually relatively easy to
automate because it's
very simple it involves routines and
rule following behavior so
it's relatively easy although it was
pretty hard to create a chess playing
computer that could
beat the best human players it's much
more difficult it turns out to create
things that are
capable of doing very kind of
fine-grained dexterous physical
movements in a
changing environment um so that
more of it said this was a paradoxic
what we think of as very complex work is
actually relatively easy to automate
but um things that we think are
straightforward and easy like
walking from across a bumpy field it
turns out to be
pretty difficult to automate yeah but
not dancing or doing backflips
based on what boston dynamics are doing
yeah i mean boston dynamics
are showing that even more of x paradox
is now becoming
less less salient um you know there's a
lot of dispute about those videos that
they release is that you know how
carefully curated they are and to what
extent these robots are really
engaging in those behaviors autonomously
without a lot of kind of
training in advance a lot of control of
the environments that they're in but i
i'm certainly impressed by the what
they've been able to achieve in the past
few years it looks like they are really
kind of pushing the boat out on on that
level of automation um but yeah i mean
kind of go back to your point
gonna lost the track a little bit there
i think we are seeing the automation
of a lot of knowledge work nowadays
particularly where that knowledge work
is somehow
you know relatively routine um
searching through information spotting
patterns and information so
you've seen that to some extent in the
medical profession with the use of
automation in diagnostic techniques
you're seeing it in the legal profession
so i teach
law at digital law school so this is the
background that i come from so you're
seeing increased automation of certain
tasks that
lawyers do now such as searching through
documents or even basic forms of legal
research
and developing legal argumentation are
now being
automated is there anything that you
think
won't become automated is there a last
bastion or some final stance
yeah i mean i'm really not sure i think
in principle i would say that there's
nothing that can't be
automated and that kind of comes from a
deep
philosophical assumption that i have is
that in a sense humans are just complex
machines
complex biological machines i don't
think there's anything
special or magical about humans there's
no supernatural
essence or soul to them that's the
perspective that i come with this from
so
in principle we could create similarly
complex machines it's been done once
nature did it through evolution so it
seems possible that we could do it
ourselves through kind of our own
intelligence or
with assistance from machines themselves
and designing more complex machines
but at the moment it seems that there's
lots of things that
aren't going under a kind of an
immediate threat of being
automated um at least you know we're not
going to have
human equivalence for certain kinds of
tasks
but it you don't always have to have
human equivalence for something to be
replaced
you can have a cheaper more efficient
robot that isn't necessarily better at a
task might still be more attractive to
uh
an employer or a business owner so
you've got to think about it in those
terms
why would technological unemployment be
desirable for us
well i mean so that kind of comes from a
combination of two things i suppose um
one is that
one of the arguments that i make in the
book in a chapter that's you know
somewhat
um i guess provocatively titled
why you should hate your job is that i
think that a lot of
a lot of work in the modern world is
pretty unpleasant it has a number of
negative features to it
and it's being made worse oftentimes by
technology even even when machines don't
completely replace humans
humans have to work alongside machines
in such a way that actually
disimproves the the quality of the of
their work
um and then i think it would be
desirable to maybe
hasten the automation of work because
there are alternatives to working for a
living
that would be better but i mean i will
say that that argument
hinges on how you define work and
kind of deeper discussion about what it
means for humans to flourish and
live better lives yeah precisely
yeah that was that was one thing i
thought about like i quite like
this job i i actually can't believe that
i've just referred to it as a job
i enjoy having these conversations i
don't want some
shiny robot bastard to come and take
this microphone off me
yeah and i mean so this is the thing
that the observation that i started that
chapter of the book with is that i quite
like my job as well i mean
one of the reasons that i like my job is
that for the most part it doesn't feel
like a job either
i i'm an academic and i get to spend
most of my time
sitting in my office at home even
pre-covert times
read books and write about things that
interest me and nobody's telling me
what to do and um i find that quite
well um self-actualizing and
meaningful i think i'm probably one of
the lucky ones and i think you're
probably one of the lucky ones too um
you know you've you've managed to kind
of craft this space for yourself this
kind of
i don't know i should preface all this
by saying i don't know exactly
everything that you do apart from this
podcast but if i assume that this
podcast is your major
form of work then it seems like you know
you've crafted a space for yourself an
audience for yourself that
um you kind of get to dictate the terms
of
your own life in a way that a lot of
people would find
enviable i suppose my observation book
is that
most of us or most people in the world
don't have that
kind of luxury and that i'm relatively
privileged in my
kind of job and what i get to do and you
are also
relative relatively privileged there's
lots of people who started podcasts who
aren't successful and uh haven't managed
to
turn into a way of life you know you're
one of the superstars out there that's
managed to do that don't people find
like
mastery and community and status and
other stuff in work they might not love
it but it gives them a sense of meaning
i remember seeing a bunch of different
studies about people who retire earlier
just how much sooner they die
yeah i mean i think work is certainly a
source of good things for people it's
a source of um as you say mastery you
can master a skill set
to gain this sense of pride and
achievement from the work that you do
it's also for many people it's their
main source of community it's it's
you know they have to work every day for
a certain number of hours and so that
they have to associate with certain
people that they work with and they
can build meaningful relationships in
that way
it's also sort of a source of social
status we live in societies
for the most part that really
valorize work and think you know having
a job
is having a stable income being able to
provide for people
that's kind of the be all in and all of
life i suppose like what i would say
about that is that
i'm certainly willing to accept that
work is a source of good things for many
people
i guess the question is whether we can
find those things
in other outlets outside of work and
whether there's a sense in which
work is a source of those things for
many people because
they have no other option that you know
work they have to work
you know it's a matter of economics
necessity for them to work they're not
going to be able to
survive without it and so they have to
find those things
and work there's no no other forum for
them to do so
and i would also say that even though
people make those claims about work
being a you know
a source of community providing a sense
of mastery and so forth
um i think it's also true for a lot of
people that it's not a source of those
things and that
actually what they do outside of work
with their hobbies with their friends
with their families is it more of a
source of meaning that work for a lot of
people is kind of
a means to an end and a form of of
drudgery i do cite this example in
in the book um and i'm certainly not
claiming that this is the only
evidence for this proposition or idea or
the best evidence but
the polling firm gallup have frequently
done these kind of state of the global
workforce
surveys every few years and one
certainly for the past decade and a half
one of their consistent findings in
those
surveys is that most people are not
actively engaged by their work in fact
i think within europe the european union
area
the average is about 10 of people are
actively engaged at work
in the us it's a little bit higher
something like 30 percent but in nowhere
in the world does it crack through like
40
50 percent of people being actively
engaged enthused by their work most
people seem to find
it kind of mundane a little bit
monotonous um
and not kind of their main source of of
pride
or um mastery and when you think that
that's something you're spending 40
000 hours of your life doing ish even if
you don't necessarily have a job for
life if you kind of vacillate from
all right job to slightly less [ __ ] job
to
whatever it might be yeah i i think
a lot of the stuff upon reading
your book you really need you need to
remove the visceral response that you
have to some of the things that come up
so for instance talking about the fact
that well don't people find community at
work and you're like well
yeah i mean they find community at work
but would you be friends with those
people
if it wasn't for the fact that you're at
work
like and if it wasn't for the fact that
you have to look up to them maybe too
well yeah and it's succeeding we're all
in this together
it's part of this sort of common cause
that we've got like
if the only thing that you and somebody
else have bonded over is the way that
you
acquire resources through somebody else
who is taking on all of the risk
you know i'm sure that you can find
soulmates both sort of romantically and
in terms of friendships
in jobs but i don't think that we should
kid ourselves that we're bonding
over the job we are in a job with
someone else
and we have managed to find common
ground between us outside of the job
and the same thing goes for everything
else like like you said status like what
does it mean to be
a carpenter farmer
hairdresser you know what pic whatever
it might be like yeah that gives you
status but is that the best status that
you could give you like is that the
highest form of
your actualization that you could have
got to and sadly we never get to split
test our own lives which i've always
thought would be
a fantastic idea like if whoever's
running the simulation could allow us to
do that
and just allow me to a b split test a
bunch of different decisions that'd be
phenomenal
but we never get to do that you don't
know if the fact that you chose to be a
hairdresser instead of a masseuse
or a pt instead of an accountant or
whatever it might be you don't ever know
that
what degree of flourishing you've
actually managed to get yourself to
yeah i mean i guess part of me thinks
that maybe that's
one of the tragedies of human life is
that we don't get to run the experiment
again
um i guess you know it's more true
nowadays that people have the
opportunity to experiment a little bit
with their profession and
as you said earlier vacillate about from
job to job and
try different things out and that's more
tolerated a lot of
people don't really you know settle down
in a kind of meaningful sense until
they're into their
their 30s probably in most developed
economies whereas
i guess you know my parents generation
you entered your job when you were 18
when you left school and
you stayed in that job for the next 40
years i mean my father
that's literally what happened to me he
entered the bank when he was
18 years old he stayed there until he
retired he left left when he was 65 yeah
so he he definitely didn't get to split
test his life he had
one one path through life and that was
the norm a generation ago so i think
we're in a little bit of a better
position when it comes
to that but your general argument or
idea
is right that um we i think there's a
probably a lot of you know post hoc
rationalization
classes well i'm in i'm in this job
i'm working with these people i have to
get along with them and you know
actually
they have some good features and yeah
i'll go for a couple of drinks with them
and
suddenly they're my my friends
for life and then my work is my source
of meaning and status because it's the
thing that can occupies my attention
all day long and so we don't we don't
get to consider those alternative
options and
see whether there are other ways in
which we could flourish there's a lot of
sunk
costs involved for a lot of people as
well and
this isn't actually something that i
already got into in the book but it's
something i talk about a lot because i
it's the thing i teach on on finance and
the world of banking and one of the
courses i teach is just
the level of indebtedness in the modern
world
and how you know people have less
disposable income
and um kind of less options uh
as a result of this and that i think
this
kind of leads to the sunk cost fallacy
in life that well i'm
i'm kind of stuck in this rush and i
can't afford
to run the alternative experiment and
it's only
probably when people really hit rock
bottom or they're forced out of
the position that they've been in that
they do get to run that
split test on their life so to speak
yeah what in your opinion
is the good life how do people find
meaning and flourishing
while we're alive
yeah well look i mean this is a topic
that
could fill a thousand podcasts and i
guess
in a sense many of your podcasts have
dealt with this theme
in the past based on what i've seen um i
don't have any like
you know radical new answers to that
question apart from repeating what
yeah philosophers and psychologists have
been been saying for
for centuries i mean on a very abstract
level
the way in which people think about the
the good life is probably a combination
of
your subjective satisfaction with your
life
you know the amount of pleasure you have
the desires that you fulfill
the goals that you achieve in life those
are markers of having a good life
and then combined with that the
objective
value of your the things that you're
doing in life what you're what you
produce for the world
what you achieve in the world whether
those are good things so
the i guess the philosophical views that
you could spend your entire life
counting the blades of grass in your
back garden and maybe like maybe you're
really
happy doing that and satisfied maybe
some
you know ai has planted a little chip in
your brain and to say that this is
you know a real source of pleasure it's
like the equivalent of crack cocaine for
you or something
but that doesn't look like a good life
in a philosophical sense because you're
not doing anything that has
you know objective value or meaning so
one of the accounts that i look at in
the book is
an account of the good life from a
philosopher called susan wolf where she
talks about
the so-called fitting fulfillment theory
of of the good life of the meaningful
life that it's
one where you're doing something that is
objectively worthwhile that is fitting
and you are fulfilled
by doing that thing and i think you
probably need that the combination of
those two things
and in terms of like what kinds of
things have objective value
well again there are standard answers to
that there's you know doing good things
for the world for other people
you know making their lives morally
better alleviating their suffering
um there's achieving kind of break
breakthroughs in
in knowledge you're producing knowledge
or information or goods that are
valuable
to others in the world and i guess it's
also like art and aesthetic
um production and appreciation as part
of
good life the philosophical slogan that
sums this up
is that things that are worthwhile in
life are the good
the true and the beautiful that's the
triumvirate
of meaning in life i'm just about to
finish the happiness hypothesis by
jonathan haye
and he finishes the book um by
contesting the happiness comes from
within
uh buddhist claim and he talks about
something similar which is happiness
comes from within and without
um and he's talking about this this
two-way street
um and i think i wonder how much of that
is part of a is jaded by a
society that's a meritocracy that's one
where you are
what you can do or very much about
creation and and um
[Music]
tacitly things being there you know we
make things happen we do stuff as a
society right now
um and i wonder whether
we do that because we know that we can
we push people to
try and create things and try and add
objective value to the world because we
know that that's an option for them
whereas if you're a a surf
in romania in like the 1400s i don't
even know if they had surfs and
remainder in the fort you know i mean
someone hoeing the fields and stuff like
that like would would it
be as uh forefront of the way the
philosophy looks it
looks at this stuff if people didn't
have the option to do it
yeah i mean this is a good question i
mean
i think that in the modern era we
probably are too wedded to this
maybe objectivist and productivist view
of what provides meaning in life that
it's it's all about producing good
things
that actually oftentimes produ doing
that for many people isn't a source of
fulfillment i guess the you know
classical
stoic view is that
um you know the only thing that you get
to control is your own kind of
perception of reality and how you
interpret events and and um how you
understand them
and that you can't rely too much on
external phenomena or
even do it producing good things in the
world because it's subject to so many
contingencies and
luck and it's a mistake to attach your
happiness to
things that aren't completely within
your control and of course
you know that idea is a feature of
a lot of modern psychotherapy too you
know cognitive behavioral therapy is
essentially premised on that
ancient stoic ideal right of controlling
your perception
of events that you shouldn't be too
attached to the approval of others
or attached to achievement as a source
of
kind of meaning and happiness in life um
so i mean there's certainly part of me
that is attracted to the
classic stoic view that you've got to
focus on your perception of events and
the things that are
within your control i do think that the
productivist
ideal of what the good life is is
dangerous in so far as a lot of those
objective goods like you know doing good
things for
the world making the world tomorrow a
better place or achieving some kind of
great
insight and some truth or producing
something of value for the world
those tend to be relatively elitist
goods like there's
there's probably only a handful of
people that really get to achieve those
objectively good things for the world
and
you know i'm not saying that i don't
it's impossible for me to do good things
for my friends and family but the actual
the scope of my influence is relatively
minimal
um so i do think it would be wise to
reign in this
attachment to producing good things as
a source of meaning and like in one
sense you could read the book that i've
written as a
as a way of arguing that arguing for
that hypothesis or for that idea
even though it's probably not something
i brought explicitly to the forefront of
the book but
now that we're talking about it it's
something that kind of occurs to me i
think it aligns as well
okay so let's say that
it is a good or someone's proposing
automation
should occur what are the strongest
criticisms against letting it happen
i mean the automation um kind of letting
it run rampant
in human life well i mean the the most
obvious
criticism of it is and this
unfortunately is not something i
engage with in the book is what does it
actually do to people's lives
from an economic perspective because at
the moment work is
uh an economic necessity for people it's
how they
gain access to an income and they need
an income in order to
survive and thrive
and you can lament that fact or regret
that fact but that's just
a reality in the modern world and
you know it's more true in some
countries than others in some countries
we have
fairly robust safety nets and welfare
that could protect people from the harsh
realities of losing their job
i guess one of the interesting features
of the covet 19 patent
is how a lot of governments have stepped
in to
provide even more supports for people
who've lost their jobs
um somewhat and reasonably generous
supports in comparison to
what was previously there although
that's always been on the
assumption that it's a temporary
stop-gap measure that keeps on getting
extended
it keeps getting extended and you kind
of wonder like how much longer can it be
extended for um but yeah i mean
so losing your income is going to be the
main
kind of objection to automation so
unless there's something done
to correct for this loss of income bring
that bring that
it's going to be pretty yeah yeah it's
going to be a pretty bad thing for a lot
of people
and you can kind of see that happening
to some extent already
um and i mean more generally i think
there are objections to
the impact that automation is having on
human well-being
not just in a purely economic sense i
discussed kind of five problems
in the book that i think are already
apparent
but are likely to get worse the more
automation there is uh one problem
is kind of linked back to the
conversation we're just having about you
know what it takes to live a good life
the sense that you need
both subjective satisfaction and some
kind of connection to the world around
you to be doing things that are good for
the world around you
um look at a very obvious point is that
the whole
purpose of automation is to
sever that link between human effort and
production in the in the world so that
you know
humans aren't needed for producing that
good and that's happening like not just
in
jobs it's also happening in other
spheres of life i mean one example that
i
look at in the book is in scientific
inquiry
like these are very kind of preliminary
um
preliminary forms of technology but
there's a group of researchers in
aberystwyth
and wales actually who've produced these
robot scientists who are able to
review the scientific literature
generate their own hypothesis
and test it um the two i think the two
robots scientists that they've created
that i remember reading about were adam
and eve they're both called have
different names and
they were doing uh fairly
you could say basic research on testing
different kinds of
creating new kinds of yeast and
different kind of drug treatments but
it's an interesting proof
of concept that you could actually have
scientists like not just assisting in
the process
of scientific inquiry but actually
autonomously
generating their own hypotheses and
testing them
and you know there's sometimes this
notion that if we don't work we'll just
kind of swan around and have more time
for
um scientific inquiry and intellectual
endeavor
people all of those things that people
are just moonlighting on an evening time
as they're
they're taking up the violin and they're
doing some
picasso in the garage and some dna
crisp editing in the on the way to work
and all this
yeah and i mean it's the reality is that
well number one a lot of people don't do
that and under the capacity to do it or
the means to do it but also
um it could be the case that automating
technologies
obviate the need for them to do that in
the first place like one of the things i
talked about in the book
and i i i'm happy to admit that it's a
it might seem to many people like a
satirical example but you know the movie
wall-e which is one of my one of my
favorite pixar movies has this depiction
of
an automated future where you have lots
of robots doing you know
basic tasks around the world and what do
the humans do in that world you know
humans are all
incredibly obese they're sitting on
floating couches in this interstellar
cruise ship trying to transport them to
a better world because they've
completely environmentally destroyed the
destroyed the earth and they're watching
you know light entertainment and being
fed
a diet of fast food so they're the kind
of almost these passive
slug-like beings because technology has
made their
life too convenient and too easy and
they don't really have the motivation to
do anything
and then you know i'm sure that's that's
satire obviously in one sense and
people have ridiculed it referring to it
as this kind of vision of the future as
the sofalarity as opposed to the
singularity where we all just end up on
ourself as but i mean part of me thinks
there's something
true to it right that humans have
although you know engaging in difficult
tasks and difficult forms of
physical labor or cognition can be very
rewarding and fulfilling
they're also very difficult to do and
need to be very kind of motivated to do
them
and if if technology means that we don't
have to do these things anymore
i think there's a danger for a lot of
people that they'll just kind of fall
back
into a very passive form of existence
i know all the problems that i discuss
in the book
the five problems that is because
they're all kind of linked to that basic
idea
this theme of passivity as a result of
automation
yeah i mean think about the rise in
stoicism like why that's happening or
why people
are enjoying doing iron man triathlons
or
brazilian jiu jitsu or cold showers cold
showers perfect example
and why do people want to do it like it
sucks
you don't nobody enjoys the cold shower
they want to feel alive
they enjoy the satisfaction they enjoy
the state change
yes precisely there's not many things
that we do now unless you skid on the
ice outside in your car
there's not many things that we do that
make us feel alive you know that give us
that sort of
there's a dominatrix who um
paul bloom interviewed for one of his
upcoming books and she said nothing
captures attention like a whip
and she means that when you slap someone
in the face as hard as you can
they're not thinking about anything for
five seconds after you've hit them
they're just thinking
did i just get [ __ ] slapped did she
just slap me that's
that's what they're thinking and i think
that uh again
naval ravicant talks about we don't want
peace of mind we want peace
from mind and this desperate desire to
kind of just
get ourselves into a lower stimulus
state in a significantly higher stimulus
world
is just a constant battle but again
if we were to be able to have some
beautifully omnipotent omnis on this
being
a agi it could solve all of those
problems in any case so anything that we
can think of any of these issues that we
can postulate
it can come up with the correct
combination of drug cocktail
the correct virtual environment for us
to be in the perfect
robot soul mate sex friend that we
need to make us feel fulfilled that
solution
should be found if you had a an agi that
was sufficiently advanced
with enough resources to be able to do
it um so okay so let's say that
we managed to replace work with
automation in an effort to get to a
utopia
like what what does it even mean to get
it right like what what is a utopia by
your definition
yeah this is another whole um
a whole other discussion in many ways
but uh
i guess one of the things i do in the
book is i contrast two
ideas of what a utopia is there's kind
of the
the traditional popular conception of
what a utopia is or
or what you find in so-called utopian
literature
which is what i call the blueprint or
blueprint model of utopia
um you find this in your plato's
republic what is the ideal city
and he has this very rigid
hierarchical society everyone knows
their place their very
set rules about what people are supposed
to be doing you get it in you know
thomas moore's classic work on utopia
first coinage of the term actually in
modern english
where he depicts this hypothetical
society
it's kind of a neo-feudalist society
where everyone is divided into these
cases and they have certain roles in
society and
you know arguably though this is this
less true in the sense that
communist theory was probably
struck by the fact that the um the
communist utopia was never very
precisely
specified but those kinds of societies
that did arise that espoused a
communist philosophy often had this kind
of rigid
authoritarian structure this so it's
implementing this blueprint the idea is
that we have this model of what the
ideal world is
and we just need to kind of match the
actual reality to that blueprint
and if that means that some people have
to be you know sacrificed along the way
for the good of the revolution for the
good of achieving this blueprint then
so be it and i think that's why
utopianism in many people's minds is a
very kind of negative set of
connotations
that it's it's associated with a lot of
failed
movements like communism critiqued as
being utopianist movement
and then it's also associated with a lot
of violence and cruelty
to utopia oddly a utopia is seen as a
very ruthless sort of thing where
people are just going to be left behind
it sort of
makes me think a lot about um
[Music]
epigenetics not an epigenetic what was
the thing that
eugenics eugenics that's it like
eugenics and stuff like selective
breeding like that's what a utopia but i
mean i'm
massively jaded obviously by precisely
the sort of
old literature and the new sci-fi that i
insist on reading to make me fall asleep
on the night time
yeah and the famous kind of philosopher
of science karl popper someone might
have heard of he
he wrote these influential critiques of
utopianism saying that they can
necessarily lead to violence because
anyone who's part of utopian movement
will just think it's
the ends justify the means so if you
have to break some eggs to make the
omelet and if that means
you know cracking heads and putting
people in prison camps so be it
that's definitely not the model of
utopianism that i favor
in in the book i contrast that with
what i call a horizonal or you could
almost call it like a frontier model of
utopia that um the ideal society is one
that is open
and dynamic right that actually doesn't
have a fixed
destination or fixed
kind of map for what the ideal society
is but that is
uh focused on not becoming static
not becoming limited that explores
different horizons of possibility for
humanity both in terms of
kind of activities in terms of how we
embody ourselves how we relate to other
people
how we explore our environment it's the
sense that there's always
more possibilities that the future can
always be better and maintaining that
open horizon
in the future is the key to having a
utopian society so it's
maybe a slightly paradoxical idea in the
sense that
a utopian society for me is not one that
has a particular fixed
model or blueprint but it's something
that is open-ended and dynamic
what's a cyborg utopia you kind of break
it into into two different types what's
a cyborg one
yeah well the last part of the book i
look at two different
models of utopia the cyborg utopia and
what i call virtual utopia
i want to kind of take a step back
before i talk about it just to explain
why i
had those two possible futures because
some people might think it's
well why did you pick those two and why
is it so binary so so where i arrive at
the end of the first half of the book is
this notion that
humanity is at a crossroads that's
what's happening
and i use this idea from evolutionary
anthropology that humans evolved to fill
what i call the cognitive niche right we
what sets us apart from other animals is
that we use our brains
both individually and collectively to
solve problems
and we kind of generate our own
ecological niche
we're not as dependent on the physical
world we're not
so uh susceptible to the whims of the
natural world as other animals because
we've
managed to carve out this niche for
ourselves using our brain power
what's happening now is that we're
creating technologies that are gradually
replacing
us that they're kind of shunting us out
of the cognitive niche pushing us out
gradually
and so we we face a dilemma and the
question is you know
do we do we try to fight back against
the machines
and reclaim our dominance of the
cognitive niche
or do we try and retreat from the
cognitive needs and
let the machines watch over us and look
after
our economic well-being or our needs our
the kind of the needs for abundance and
affluence and so forth
and do something else and so i associate
those kind of two options with two
different models of
utopia the cyborg utopia which is where
we basically try to become
like the machines that are gradually
replacing us
and the virtual utopia which is where we
essentially retreat from the cotton of
nation do something else
what i think is really interesting about
that is it it makes me think
about the status conversation that we
were having before
about your job sort of gives you your
sense of who you are
and it's the label you give yourself and
that
cognitive niche is kind of like a
species-wide
status that we've given ourselves right
like
we are the cognitive kings of the jungle
you know there isn't anything else that
we know in the universe
that's smarter than us that has the
powers of abstraction
and planning and mindfulness and all of
the creativity everything that we
value for the big meatloaf inside of our
heads
pretty soon unless the
um unless agi continues to remain
narrow and go deeper as opposed to
actually being able abroad now and it
does seem like there is a bit of debate
about whether or not that's going to
happen
um but if it is able to get to proper
nick boss from shitty pants stuff
then we're no longer going to be top of
the tree we are we are literally going
to be
in a best case scenario
friends with a god
that we have managed to constrict into
constrict or convince to align
its goals and ours together but we are
no longer going to be
top of the tree and i wonder what that
does
to a civilization when that happens
like what does it mean to be a human
what does it mean to be supposedly the
rulers of a planet when you're no longer
the smartest
individual on it yeah i mean that's a
really interesting way of
kind of framing it or putting it that
yeah the
our our brain power is the status that
we've given ourselves as a species i
guess
you know evolutionists hate this notion
that we are part of some chain of being
and we
we're it's a hierarchy and we you know
sit at the top of it and they would
argue that
you know the whole point of evolutionary
thinking of the darwinian revolution is
to
[Music]
rid us of that notion that we are
somehow at the center of the
evolutionary
universe that um it's just this kind of
big
kind of massive sprawling branch uh
branching tree of different organisms
but
yeah i think the reality is that many
human civilizations and many humans
probably do
think of themselves as in some sense
superior to the rest of the world and
this notion that we're going to lose
that status um
is is problematic and i think it does
pose a major existential threat to us
not not in the bostromian sense of like
the machines are going to turn us into
paper clips
but in the sense that what are we here
for what's the purpose
of it all oh yeah so not only could we
be paper clips but
mentally we could think of ourselves as
paper clips so there's two different
ways
that we could be we could be displaced
both spiritually and
physically we could get displaced by the
machines okay so yeah
cyborg cyborg utopia give us the what's
that look like
yeah i mean there's a number of
different ideas or pathways to cyborg
utopia out there
for people who aren't aware of i know
most people are aware of this nowadays
you know cyborg
is a cybernetic organism actually the
the concept or idea comes from a paper
written by a
couple of scientists who have very
suspiciously similar
surnames but they're spelled differently
so
i don't actually remember their first
names ever but it's kleins and klein is
there
the names of people who wrote this paper
um
on the cyborg and they were actually
writing as part of the space race like
they were
talking about you know how can we get
humans into space and they're commenting
on the fact that well you know humans
aren't very well adapted to space
uh if you you put us outside a spaceship
for a couple of seconds we're gonna
you know not not not be thriving and
flourishing to put it mildly
so how can we improve things well we
could we could turn
humans into machines or we could
integrate human biological systems with
machines so that we're better adapted to
the environment of space
and that's the that's where the term
cyborg came from from their paper that
they wrote about this idea
and obviously it's been taken on a whole
other life since in in
popular culture but i mean that's
basically what i'm talking about when i
look at the cyborg utopia is that
we kind of fight back against the
machines by trying to become
machines ourselves by by integrating
ourselves more and more with machines so
that
who we are is part and
parcel of like what automating
technology is as well
so our fates are are bound together not
just in a
kind of loose sense but in the sense
that we are the same thing
and the our identity is the same as them
now there's two probably different
pathways to achieving cyborg status
you could achieve it by actually
physically integrating yourself with
technology
one of the examples i discussed in the
book is this artist
neil harbisson i don't know if you've
ever interviewed him you should probably
try an interview much he's an
interesting guy um
he he's a founder of the cyborg society
and more recently the
the trans species society who's
advocating for the rights of
people who don't ascribe to a human
identity so i think this might be
something that
is intriguing to you post-human identity
um
so he has this uh antenna at the back of
his head
and he was born colorblind and what this
antenna does is it converts light rays
into sound
so it allows him to to hear in color all
right so it
it's a bit of technology that i guess
you could call it a technology
a technologically induced form of
synesthesia he's combining two senses
and um he he talks about this a lot and
how it changes his kind of sensory
perception and engagement with the world
so what he's doing there literally is
using a piece of technology to change
how
he experiences reality he's integrated
himself with the technology and in
interviews that he's conducted he he
refers to himself as a bit of technology
says you know i'm not
it's not that i use technology to
engage with the world i am kind of an
extended piece of technology my identity
with this
antenna that i've drilled into my skull
is
um it's part of me and like he's won the
right to kind of wear it in
um identity photographs and all that
kind of thing so he's an interesting
character
like it's a very primitive form of
cyborg technology he's just kind of
adding a new sensory modality but it's i
think
a proof of concept of how we can
integrate ourselves with
machines and there are lots of other
people doing similar
experiments or developing similar cyborg
technologies you know brain computer
interfaces that allow people to
have like robotic arms that are directly
attached into their nervous system
it's usually for people who've suffered
from some kind of um
amputation or loss of limb function
or you have these exoskeletons that
people are creating that allow you to
kind of lift heavier objects and move
faster
and these are all examples of kind of
technical integration
between our biological systems and
either a computer or robotic system in
some way
so that's one form of cyber organization
there's another form as well
it's just kind of a loser for him that
some people say that we are kind of
cyborgs already there's a
scottish philosopher called andy clark
who says that
you know we're natural-born cyborgs that
again kind of go back to this idea of
the cognitive niche you know how did we
succeed how do we thrive within the
cognitive
niche was because we built technologies
that we
have tied our faith to that humans have
always been a technological species have
used technology to to survive and
we're just doing more and more of that
nowadays and we've become kind of
highly interdependent with um our
technologies
you know it's a trite example but the
notion that like
how close you are to your phone and how
often you look at your phone and how
reliant you are on your phone for memory
for navigation
uh for financial management whatever it
might be that's an example of kind of
cyber organization but that's a
i think a looser metaphorical sense of
what it means to become a cyborg and
i'm kind of more interested in the
technical form of cyber organization
it's an interesting thought experiment
that i've just been going through in my
head there
thinking about i don't think that i'm a
cyborg even if the phone the phone's
outside of me it's not me
right okay so let's say that
everybody within the next 300 years gets
a robotic
set of hips because hips are a nightmare
and we don't want okay
like no no no because that's just that's
just the robot and then you just
slippery slope your way all the way down
and you go okay so now i've got robotic
legs okay so now
now 80 percent of me all the way up to
the nips or all the way up to the neck
like that that's all robotic we've just
dispensed with our bodies but our heads
are still there
or reverse it and say okay maybe we've
realized that actually
we can replace certain areas of the
brain like we can get rid of fear
fear and anxiety response by getting rid
of like the way the amygdala works and
we can put a
chip in in place of that and it's kind
of the same size in the same shape
and slippery slope your way all the way
down through that as well and you go
right okay now the hippocampus is gone
now like the prefrontal cortex is gone
now this is gone you actually get to a
point
where you can remove all parts of you
and replace them with a machine and yet
somehow still consider that you're not a
machine
um just i think because we hold on to
our sense of
i am me and it's very difficult to
abstract ourselves into what would it be
like for my consciousness to be placed
in something else
you know we understand what happens when
we see someone in a wheelchair they are
not
the wheelchair but at what point does
replacing the parts of you that you
consider to be you and this is a broader
question that sam harris asks a lot
which is he says like where are you
you consider that you're somewhere in
your head behind your eyes
but really like what are we talking
about here
um and i suppose this is a this is a
much deeper sort of philosophical
question
but certainly when you talk about
cyborgs it does it certainly seems that
from some sort of objective metric
it would be quite feasible to think of a
situation
in which we were cybernetic organisms
yeah and look as i say there are there
are many people who argue that
there are already humans that are
cyborgs you know
kind of neural prosthetics the use of
retinal implants cochlear implants
you know they're not replacing parts of
your cortex yet
but they are replacing parts of your
kind of
sensory peripheries and it seems like a
very
good clear proof of concept that you
could
do more kind of fun functional
integration with technical systems and
the more of that we do the more
technology like we become the more
we become cyborgs um you know there is
an interesting philosophical question is
that like if you
replace every single neuron in your head
gradually over time
do you actually maintain the same
identity or is there a certain point in
time in which the lights switch off and
you know there's some philosophers who
think that maybe that will happen like
maybe
as you're gradually replacing each
neuron you seem like you're still inside
your skull or inside your body but then
at some point suddenly it all
disappears uh like like a cybernetic
zombie
yeah yeah exactly i mean there have been
people who argued that
that that might be possible and that
we'll never know and that's the problem
because you never get to see well
i had um a bunch of conversations
recently
about consciousness philip gough was on
talking about consciousness
and um the the
my favorite quote from that reminded me
of something i'd read ages ago which is
if it wasn't for the fact that we
experienced it the universe would give
us no indication that consciousness
existed
yeah exactly right yeah so that's that's
the problem
somebody could be walking around with uh
[Music]
making the noises doing the movements
having the responses
wouldn't know okay so cyborg utopia
sounds all right
a little bit of work to be done on it
what's virtual utopia
right and so this is a much a much more
kind of slippery concept i think and
something that's it's difficult
to wrap your your head around uh partly
that's because
the the concept of what virtual reality
is is
kind of inherently paradoxical and maybe
not well understood
like one so what within the book i
contrast kind of two ideas of what
a virtual reality is um one is i guess
the
the technical sense of it where you know
you're literally
putting on like a headset or something
and going inside a computer simulated
environment and living out a life
like that idea depicted in in lots of
movies i guess
the matrix is a famous variation on this
idea of living in a virtual world
through technology and uh there are
other examples that
don't spring to mind all of a sudden
this was my favorite example is
the neil stevenson book snow crash and
if anyone's ever
read that about the metaverse i've tried
so
here's the main question of this i've
started to try and get into that
twice and i've just kind of got stuck a
few pages deep it just doesn't
grip me is it worth reading yeah it is
worth reading it's it's quite
dated and i guess like you you'll be
familiar with a lot of the concepts in
it but i think that's largely because
he's been quite influential
in you know tech culture and silicon
valley culture
and do you reckon i should give it a go
i recommend you give it a go i do have
that problem with a lot of neil
stevenson books though in that
several of them are gathering dust on my
shelves and you know they're
they're all like a thousand pages long
or yeah yeah yeah
2000 page multi-volume books did you um
did you try seven eaves
i did so that that's probably i'm at a
similar point with 70s oh
you might be able to please keep up that
i can i promise you
that one is worth it
neil if you're listening i'm sorry mate
but the second
the final third of that book after
you'll know the point at which it's the
final third
the final third of that book just didn't
need to be there like the first two
thirds of it once you get into it i
couldn't put it down
i went on a stag do
to new york and someone recommended that
i start reading it
let's remember that i've been i've been
sort of going at it fairly hard for
four days in new york and it was a 10
hour plane journey home or whatever
i didn't sleep so i opened seven eaves
and 230 pages later or whatever the hell
i'd done i hadn't bothered sleeping i
got to
amsterdam absolutely wrecked uh but like
i knew what had happened uh 500 days
after the
moon had exploded or whatever it was and
yeah that was a bizarre experience
anyway we've
we've got sidetracked so uh virtual
utopia
yeah um so so this idea of like living
in a computer simulated environment
that's what living in a virtual world is
you know some people can argue that's
utopian and
part of me thinks that there's there is
potential to it in so far as you can
create an endless
space of possible worlds to live out
your life in and it's kind of this
perfect fantasy
playground for whatever it is that you
happen to desire
in principle depends on whether the the
technology gets there
there is another sense of what a virtual
life is
that i i'm more attracted to which is
the notion
again that that humans have always in a
sense been constructing a virtual world
for themselves
kind of again to go back to my point
about the cognitive niche and just kind
of flip it around
what i said is that we're using our
brain power to make ourselves
less susceptible to the visitudes of the
natural world like we're less subject to
its
its whims and it's caprice we we live
inside nice
safe controlled environments and coming
to you from a centrally
heated artificially lit room right
so i'm not outside in the siberian
winds that are certainly sweeping across
the the british isles this evening right
so i'm kind of we've always been
constructing these artificial
environments and
we're going to continue to do it it's
just that um
the kind of stakes associated with it
the the kinds of lives that we live in
these artificially constructed
environments are
going to be less um
they're going to have less stakes
associated with them insofar as
what we're doing inside them is not
going to determine our our fate in life
our economic destiny in life
so the the israeli kind of historian and
futurist you know as well yuval noah
harari has made this point
right that he actually
made it in a very short op-ed in the
guardian a few years ago but it's a
it's a major theme of both of his first
two books sapiens and
homodes that what is distinctive about
human civilization is that we use our
imaginations
to kind of project a layer onto our
experience of the world that isn't
really there
you know we perceive these status
hierarchies these kind of mythical
symbols and meanings
that actually aren't really in the
physical environment so his argument is
that
humanity is in a sense built on a series
of virtual reality games that we're
playing in our head
and so people who worry about the end of
work and the automation of work that
we're going to lose
something important are misguided
because
we're all we've always been constructing
these new virtual reality games and
we're just going to continue doing it in
the future it's just not going to be
an economic game anymore it's going to
be some other kind of
virtual reality game that we're playing
and that's
the model of the virtual utopia that i
defend in the book this
what i call the utopia of games where we
engage in lots of different game-like
activities
um and you know they're very meaningful
to us and we have achievements within
those games we build
friendships within those games but we're
not playing those games because
of some economic necessity because we're
forced to
and my claim is that it's possible for
us to construct an infinite number of
these
games to play and that can be
a kind of utopia
a lot of the objections that i sort of
observed coming up inside myself as i'm
hearing you talk and as i read the book
um can be answered again by
a sufficiently powerful or sufficiently
high fidelity
simulation um so one of the things that
i was thinking was
well isn't struggle a part of what gives
life meaning
like which wouldn't a virtual hedonic
adaptation kick in at just progressively
higher and higher levels
but the virtual reality if it was
programmed by something sufficiently
intelligent
would know that you need to have
struggle in order to get meaning
therefore the struggle would be
programmed in and
we get to a question about
if it's a it's like the reverse
philosophical zombie it's like the
environment zombie like if you
experience everything in the environment
which gives you all of the stimuli that
you would have needed
to lead a fulfilled and meaningful and
flourished life
but it's not in the real environment is
there anything different going on
yeah so like i mean my view is that
there isn't ultimately or
i mean there might be something
different but it's not
it's not a difference that kind of
renders our lives less flourishing or
less
less meaningful that said like there is
a
you know a large school of opposition to
this idea this is a philosophical
robert nozick who you know i quite like
as a philosopher he's better known as a
political philosopher
he could have defended a version of
libertarianism and minimal state
libertarianism back in the 70s that
is very influential in the us but um i i
kind of like him more as a
more general philosophy i think he has
lots of interesting ideas and he has
this famous thought experiment of the
experience machine which is
basically what you're imagining so you
know imagine you could plug yourself
into an artificial
simulation that was you know high
fidelity very realistic
you didn't you wouldn't remember your
old world life in the real world
um you could kind of play out whatever
simulation you want
would you choose to plug into the
experience machine
and he argued that he wouldn't because
he wants to live in the real world and
the experience machine would be missing
something that he desires
and he claimed to have surveyed his
students on this and that they all
agreed with him and a lot of people i
think when first presented with this
thought experiment
agree with it it turns out more recently
there's a bunch of experiments that have
been done on this
where people have asked kind of
variations on the original
experience machine thought experiment
where they say well okay
what if instead of um plugging into a
machine
you were asked to plug out of a machine
so you were told well everything that
you value in your life right now
is a simulation and you you can plug out
of that simulation going to the real
world
basically the thought experiment that's
depicted in the movie the matrix would
you choose to do it
and some of the experimental studies in
this suggests that actually people
wouldn't choose to do it or they're less
likely to choose to do it
significantly less likely to just do it
if they're plugging out of the machine
so some people have argued that a
nozick's
thought experiment was playing upon a
kind of status quo by us yes
people are attached to their current way
of life and they're afraid to kind of
move out of it and it's not really
saying anything about whether
living inside this virtual reality
machine is actually valuable or
meaningful or not
this is like a virtual reality trolley
problem
like an inverted virtual reality trolley
problem
is there a case here i'm going to guess
that there will be people will be pretty
swayed by a naturalistic fallacy as well
yeah i mean i yeah i think you can see
that in
kind of some aspects of the modern
environmentalist movement not i'm not
going to denigrate all
forms of environmentalism by any stretch
of the imagination and i think we are
facing into some major environmental
catastrophes in the future though
i'm not sure that we can actually do
anything about them or whether we have
the collective
will or the institutions that can do
anything about it but i think there are
serious problems but
that said you know within the
environmental movement you can find kind
of pockets that are very much attached
to some kind of golden age that was in
the past or
kind of a primitivist life where we're
more in touch with nature
i think a lot of that is kind of
mythical and
an overstatement and an
over-idealization of the past which has
always been
a feature of human in life i mean there
is an argument as to why that happened
you know the kind of garden of eden myth
that you find
one of the standard historical
explanations of that is that this was
people who
had undergone the agricultural
revolution wishing that they were
hunter-gatherers again
because it turns out if you you know if
you study hunter-gatherer tribes
um nowadays and if you look at some
historical
records of them it seems that they had
much kind of
more leisure filled lives than we do and
seem to have been
maybe happier than we were this guy
called marshall's salons wrote this
famous paper back in the
60s called the original the original
affluent society or the original
leisure society which he said the 100
gatherers were the original leisure
society because
if you look at them what they do is they
spend maybe two hours a day working
instead of looking for food
and then the rest of the time is spent
kind of playing hanging around with
their
families and not doing much else um
so like it could be that people are
appealing to that kind of mythical ideal
but i think there's lots of unpleasant
features of that
form of life too in terms of the disease
the disease the teeth falling
intertribal warfare
yeah the rampant rape yeah i am
i had david pierce on the show
transhumanist guy
sure yeah yeah yes i had david on the
show it must be years ago now it must be
a couple of years ago and um
prior to prior to speaking to him
i think i had a very different sort of
view around
us moving forward but in the way that
ideas oddly do
tend to infect you because i spoke to
him so long ago and because i've
reflected on
the stuff that he does for quite a while
that status quo bias like my overton
window of what i consider to be a mental
projection of where we could end up as a
civilization
has just it's just sort of expanded and
expanded and expanded and now i'm like
well i mean you know if there was a way
of virtually
essentially making me feel like on mdma
all the time
and never come down from it and just
exist that degrees of human enjoyment
that have
hereto never been discovered i'm like
is there it becomes a question it
becomes an ethical question
it's it simply comes down to that as far
as i can see
yeah i mean like i think david's work is
um kind of groundbreaking and
definitely you could have perspective
shifting work his book the
hedonistic imperative which i believe
you can access the entire text of it
online it was written back in the 90s i
believe
so it's it might seem a little bit dated
in some aspects but it's still
i think a very provocative and current
work and
will really kind of reshape your
thinking about
i guess the big idea within it is the
notion that
some people can have a lower hedonistic
baseline than everyone else and
that means they're kind of disadvantaged
and they live a more impoverished life
and that we can we should do something
to kind of
up the hedonistic ante for them to kind
of live more
flourishing blissful lives and so he's a
i would say an alternative model of the
utopia
to me but it's not entirely december and
you know david is a
transhumanist and i guess what i talk
about when i talk about the cyborg
utopia
is a kind of transhumanist future you
know david
reduces transhumanism to the so-called
three supers
that the goal is super longevity you
know ending
death and or maybe not ending death
rather but
having extra long lives uh super
intelligence
creating more and more intelligence and
improving human intelligence and then
super happiness
which is this idea of the hedonistic
imperative making people more blissful
and happy um and i think i think that
kind of
chimes with what i view as the cyborg
utopia i'm a little bit more
dismissive of that idea in the book but
in favor of the virtual utopia but
i'm not completely down on the cyborg
utopia i think it has
merits as well what i'm skeptical about
is its technological feasibility in the
medium term
what is going to happen next do you
think in the space of not
the science side but in terms of
philosophy what do you think
people are going to spend the next five
to 10 years thinking about with regards
to this space do you have any
inclination of that
well i mean i guess like a lot of my day
job is focusing on
the ethical implications legal
implications of
artificial intelligence and robotics um
i hate to call myself an ai ethicist or
anything like that because
i think that term is loaded and a lot of
the work that these people
these people that aisses do is not very
similar to what to what i do but i think
the the main
debates there are unfortunately i think
your very traditional debates about
political power like who controls
technology
and who controls access technology
you're seeing these these things play
out
uh the the effect of artificial
intelligence on political polarization
and debate the effect that it has on
economic polarization
and inequality um
issues of like bias in technology
and biased decision making i i i know
i've been talking about the
previous book that i did but i actually
i'm a co-author on a a new book
which looks at a lot of these themes
it's called um i actually have it here
this wasn't intentional if i just have
it next to me um
called the a citizen's guide to
artificial intelligence
which looks like that out now it's out
at the end of february i'm sorry
i'm not the lead author on it but it
might be a good idea to get the
the lead authorities called john zarilli
to talk about it
i'll link um a link to that in the show
notes below i've got brian christian on
next week yeah yeah okay cool the
alignment problem
um book yeah yeah i just i just
purchased that i haven't read it yet
it'll be gathering dust next to seven
eves um
yeah i mean i i know that the audience
do enjoy this
um but it's they they'd better continue
enjoying it because i
find discussions about the ethics to do
with
artificial intelligence and automation
and robots and all that stuff i find
them
endlessly fascinating i find them
fascinating in a way
that i don't think classical philosophy
has
it's not a replacement but it's a a
fantastic side dish
um and it's satisfying it's probably
getting a lot of the
debates and classical philosophy within
kind of ai and robotics
related philosophy it's just it might
seem more kind of current and
interesting
so that's like that new book is where
you think the
a lot of the direction will be going
yeah like what i'd say is i think there
are like medium term issues and
long-term issues so
you're the bostrom super intelligence
existential risk angle
that's sort of the the long-term debate
and concerns and then the short medium
term debate is about like
effect on work you cannot the economy
the effect on on politics political
debate polarization
and the the legal uses of ai like
the use of predictive tools to determine
whether somebody is going to commit a
crime again
or in child welfare protection these
kinds of things these those are all
examples that we discussed
in that book so that's why i'm i'm
raising them um
that's where a lot of the conversation
is now it's an interesting
question as to why those two
conversations are actually quite
separate in
the philosophical legal communities and
they probably shouldn't be they
should actually be more joined up and
i'd be
one of the people who'd be arguing for
them to be more joined up
but i think there are some people who
are very dismissive of the long-term
concerns
they think they're too speculative to
fanciful and that we should
limit ourselves to the more medium-term
concerns but i
i think you have to focus on both and i
think the long-term yeah i think you
have to have a long-term
perspective otherwise i think you're
missing out on a lot of
what is interesting about the human
project
there's also a a risk here the black
ball out of the urn or the
the black swan or the unknown unknowns
whatever you want to call it
like if you decide to take if you decide
to take your eye off a ball which is a
civilization killer
which even has a infinitesimal chance of
doing it
like it's it's not a very good idea
um i mean dude i got i thought i knew
existential risk and i
read uh toby odds the precipice last
year
and that that book made me fully [ __ ]
myself
um i was like
i couldn't i just can't believe
how far public attention and public
consciousness is directed in completely
the wrong area
when it comes to this you mentioned um
sort of the environmental movement
earlier on and i i angered a lot of
people
across multiple different social media
domains um about a month ago where i
said
i posted the table of tobeyord's
chance of us being destroyed within the
next century by
and he lists all the different
existential risks and the caption was
um climate change is not an existential
risk priority changed my mind
uh and a lot an awful lot of people got
very angry because the wording was
purposely provocative um but is as far
as i can see
by anyone that understands what's going
on true um
and if we were to have a sufficiently
powerful super intelligence
that would probably be able to fix and
undo any of the damage that we've done
to the environment in any case but if
it's turned us all into [ __ ] paper
clips or
stuck electrodes in our face and it kind
of doesn't matter
yeah i mean again i don't want to
reopen the kind of worms that you uh
open for yourself on twitter but um
i suppose like you know toby art is a
very kind of narrow definition of what
an existential risk is
like it has to be basically something
that's civilization ending that ends
uh humanity and uh climate change could
make things very unpleasant for a lot of
people
but humans as a general population will
survive it no doubt as they have
survived significant climatic events in
the past
before we tumble down further down that
uh that rabbit hole i have
your other book here automation and
utopia human flourishing in a world
without work
will be linked in the show notes below
anywhere else that people should go and
check out also your new book will be
linked as well any other stuff people
should go and see
um i guess just my website it has a
complicated title it's philosophical
disquisitions maybe something to link in
the show notes as well
um it's a it's a blog like i write
regular articles on it and i also have a
podcast of my own that deals with um
ai and philosophy and ethics
issues so people might be interested in
that if they're interested in this
conversation
amazing john thank you man all right
thank you
[Music]